we will talk about optimization based uh
approach for quantum signal processing
and its energy landscape
okay yeah thank you and uh thank the
organizers for invitation
it's a great pleasure to give a talk
here and the qsp
optimization which is a non-convex
optimization problem
so this is a joint work with jurong dome
who's uh
grass skilled and joint advised by
brigitta
and myself and he's a part on euro in
the sense that he's currently
a grad student in the chemistry
department and he made his own euro move
to the math department and will
start his full and also joshua wang was
a graduate
in the math department of berkeley also
xiaomi
was a visiting undergrad student and
were drawing mit is full
so this is the plan i'm going to talk
about
the optimization based algorithms for
finding the silver phase factors
i'm going to introduce what the problem
is i'm going to talk about some
newer things still working preparation
not on archive yet
the energy landscape result and if time
allows i'm going to mention briefly
a new optimization algorithm based on
the
matrix product state structure and talk
about
one open question so
i remember that for me
i have been in the quantum thing only
quite recently and what motivated me
to drawing this direction was really
due to the quantum summer cluster
that andrew umesh and others uh
organized in the summer of 2018
i remember andres uh announced this qsvt
result on board
i thought it was really interesting now
a few months ago this is a paper
came from a microtrons group
that says this qsvt really offers a
grand unification of quantum algorithms
i won't talk much about that
i refer you to the preprint as well as
the
original paper it's uh now i have to say
that honestly this is not the
easiest paper i've read but it is a very
informative one
so uh this uh is the
definition of quantum signal processing
i think uh uh
it was a terminology coin by laurentron
in 2017.
uh so there are actually two parts of it
the first part is a scalar
representation of a polynomial here
p x is a polynomial with respect to a
single variable x
that's it defined on minus one to one
and
you want to represent this complex
polynomial
in this pretty weird way here z is the
party z
gate and w x is this 2 by 2 matrix
so you compute some a phase
rotation times a w phase rotation times
w so on and so forth and
each of them using su 2 2 by 2 unitary
matrix
you multiply them still in su 2 and
for practical reasons you only focus on
the upper left part
so uh yeah if this is the first time you
see it
this will appear again again in the top
and this is what is called quantum
signal processing
the value of this uh very
non-traditional at least to me
representation of polynomials is because
once you have such a representation you
can immediately convert this
to certain eigenvalue transformations of
hermitian matrices
as well as a singular value
transformations of
pre-general matrices using this
following universal
circuit which is why the name grand
unification
so i would say that at this point if
you're still listening
there one you can do one of the two
things
one is you have already known good stuff
then there's nothing good to do
or this is really the first time you've
seen this then you can completely forget
about
uh what is here because it has nothing
to do with the rest of the talk
and you only focus on is a scalar
problem
so what i'm showing the reason why i'm
showing this slide
is just to say there's a very good
reason why we care about
this very non-traditional polynomial
representation problem
so this thing you don't need to memorize
this either it will
appear again again okay reputation
number one
so um uh the goal of the qsp
is when you represent the real
polynomials
can be written as follows you have a
polynomial
f x uh with a single variable x
it's a polynomial of degree d it's an e
it has a definite parity it's either
even or off
and another technical condition we
uh ask the f to satisfy is that
a minus one to one it should be smaller
than one when this is equal to one
there's some weird things happening so
just to say without loss of generality
it's smaller than one
so the goal of so-called defining phase
factors
is the following problem we want to find
uh
five equal to five zero double that five
e
which are d plus one numbers so that
um you multiply uh given this by
uh which are encoded here and here and
here you multiply
these things together because the code
again w
is this matrix you don't really don't
need to memorize this form
so each of them is two by two matrix and
on the upper left part you take that
which is the one one two three or in the
one
location zero zero the real part of it
is called fx so so really the first time
you see it seems
overly convoluted but uh let me
say again that all of these steps are
necessary in order to get
useful on the circuit data so a
beautiful part
is that for any of this
function satisfying this condition seems
pretty general
the solution is guaranteed to do this
which means that
this by choosing a proper set of phase
vectors
you can always encode this f once you
have this
you can actually use the previous
quantum circuit to do harmful simulation
saw linear systems and blah blah blah
many things
okay but once upon a time which is 2018
space factors were considered pretty
hard to compute
so this is a paper by andrew and
collaborators um
yes so in this appendix
they wrote this however this computation
which means computing phase factors
is difficult in practice so we can only
carry it out
for very small instances specifically
we found the time required to calculate
the angles
the same space factors to be prohibited
if it is larger than 32
it is a natural open problem to give a
more practical method to complete the
space factors
and very soon
progresses were made virtually at the
same time
this was the previous geo gslw paper
but also by top in 2018
they proposed algebraic methods
to compute which relies on computing
roots
for the high degree polynomial for high
precision
with the standard double precedent
arithmetic we can properly go to
about tens to hundreds of phase factors
you can use
variable procedure and horizontally
implemented at the software level
which is very very slow and uh
and you can go to larger uh let's say
maybe towards going to thousands of
trade factors
which is still pretty good compared to
the like 32
this is what we announced the last year
before the
lockdown in the quantum workshop
here and so we developed
an optimization-based algorithm there is
no reverse to
why it works but in practice it has been
shown to be very robust
it all already uses the standard
arithmetic and can robustly compute more
than ten thousand fixed factors
which is a polynomial degree ten
thousand
um very pretty much at the same time
paper by chao and rush and collaborators
they propose the technique
i think there are more than one
technique was presented in this paper
i think the real main idea is really is
capitalization which is
based on some small pervasion again
there's no rigorous to
why it works uh the good news is you can
also
use the standard brazil arithmetic to
compute a very large number of face
assets
and you shouldn't take these numbers to
the from their face value i think
probably
for both techniques we can compute much
larger number of phase factors
but pretty much this problem is
practically solved
right compared to what i just showed you
before
this is prohibited from 32 within two
years or so
i mean we can compute 10 000 polynomials
for a long long time quantum computers
won't be able to
carry out such expensive calculations
so at the end i will also
uh i find talked about i said a new
average
uh based on matrix product save
structure where i actually have some
local conversions results from fixing
natural gas
but it will also imply that you can say
something like
rigorous for this method okay let me now
talk about this optimization based uh
algorithm what that is
um first of all if you have a polynomial
of degree d because of a parity
constraint
you don't have that many degrees of
freedom it's about the p over two
degrees of freedom
uh because we're talking about the real
polynomial which means that
the the polynomial is completely
determined
by the uh its values sampled on
detailed points let's say uh for
numerical stability
we sample them on the chapter so close
to one is pretty dense
and close to zero as much as possible
but this is only one choice and then
uh you can naturally formulate the
problem of finding face factors as a
minimization problem
which means that i want to minimize the
objective
function so that the
this guy is a polynomial this guy
evaluated on which would be xk
sorry so evaluated on this case not on
this detailed
points uh all of them at each at this
point
is an equal sign which means it's zero
so you're looking for
the f5 to be zero and five is just a
d plus one phase values the
global minimum as i said because of the
solution guaranteed to exist
means that phi star uh must
satisfy that f5 star zero
and notice that there's a dimension
mismatch here which is
the f only has the tilde d over 2
about the over 2 degrees of freedom but
the number of variables
e is much bigger than the total so
there's no way that the solution can be
therefore the first step important step
to
make the solution possibly unique is
sort of the symmetrical psp
by the way the software is available
right if you're
interested so recall that uh
this qsp you just modify all
those by two matrices and
you end up with this kind of
representation a general qsp
on signal processing says this q
is a complex polynomial however
if you're only interested in a real part
without
loss of generality you can restrict the
queue to be real
this has the benefit that it can
immediately prove the
excuse real then the phase factors can
be chosen to be symmetric
in the sense that it goes like a plot
zero by one
and all the way when it reaches the
kyota and
you just do a mirror symmetry and it
goes to five one
by zero then you do a number of variable
counts
this is exactly matches that so there is
some hope the solution is unique
if you hold them hook though then later
i'm going to show you this is a
very far away from that but at least
nominal is there something
the modified optimization algorithm then
becomes
uh this phi the restrict will be the
symmetric phase factors
and you you compute the listening for
this
g is that the real part of the one
computer
okay so show you some examples how this
works
uh after converge is very very fast uh
this is a
psp representation for one word
x which is used to
solve linear systems because uh if you
plug
a to in place of x this becomes like a
inverse
so you're doing a inverse times b which
allows you to solve linear systems
uh it's a pretty high degree polynomial
300
and the condition number total set to 10
and this is a
polynomial at the iteration number six
uh you can see that
the error is already weighted and i will
not
but let me also show you the
uh let me also show you uh a
movie of this thing can you see the
movie
i'm not sure yes we can yeah
start from the first iteration you can
see
it was already pretty good and really uh
at each iteration
in other manners so and very quickly
convergence and this behavior is rather
generic
and uh some other applications such as a
component simulation
which is your computing qsp
representation for cosine tau x and
sine cox things like that uh if you
compare
with the font and gsm w on this part of
here
so the the
optimization based method can be one or
two others
faster and a key reason is because
the number of bits that's used if you
restrict
the number of bits to be the number
based in double crochet in arithmetic
there's absolutely no way
you can get anyone basically but
if you allow yourself to increase the
number of bits you can see it's
pretty pretty you might need to use 3
000 bits literally
to factorize with polynomials and then
you can compute them accurately
but the optimization-based method you
always use that with zero
it works similar performance for various
other applications as well
so this optimization-based procedure
also streamlines the process of finding
phase vectors
because they have at least the two
options to do so now
what i'm talking about is you're no
longer have
a polynomial but you only have a smooth
function or even a nonsense function
such as formula so
you have a you have a smooth function
let's say
then you have two options one is to
numerically obtain
the near best polynomial approximation
for example
randy's method and then you together
with numerical translation you can find
with these vectors
or in some cases you directly do the
optimization that
also works but numerically what we
observe is that option one seems to be
numerically more stable
because if you're doing a polynomial
right the optimization really find the
polynomial
you know that when
you reach the global minimum which is uh
objective
of objective function equals to zero so
one test is green
so this is what we implemented in this
qst pack
so uh now so now the method works
uh let me talk about some new things
which is energy landscape
uh the first first we thought um
okay maybe the dimension
now matches uh there's no
local medium but then that's completely
not true you see the algorithm
if you start from the wrong thing uh it
gets that local minimum all the time so
definitely
and then let's say maybe the global
minimum
is unique but that's not true either
already when you just have two
independent metric phase factors
which are the cases for example just two
examples here
if you have an even target function x
squared minus
one top function here and
um the benefit is that you don't have
two variables so you can do a contour
and the domain is compact so you will
see the entire
landscape there's nothing escaping here
so
um what you can see is that so there are
actually some symmetry structures some
of them are equivalent but
we definitely see that from minus pi to
pi minus five pi
you will see multiple global minima
so the global minimum is not unique
and similar here for the author but
this seemingly simple but there is no
local minimum by the way we have two
uh only have two phase factors
but as long as you get the degree to be
a little bit larger
let's say you will start to see local
minima and this is one of them
and you kind of like define the local
minima
you dynamize the hessian and
the smallest the singular eigenvalue of
the fashion
bigger than zero and the function value
is also bigger than zero so
definitely and there are many many of
those
so um it might become
completely hopeless we really thought so
for a long time
this is uh such a non-linear non-convex
optimization with many many global
minima with many many local
how can you say anything about this
problem
um well it turns out you can actually
say something to the first
thing is um the first step
is to get some uniqueness yourself
the uniqueness of the following um is
not
the optimization problem i said earlier
where you only know the real part of
this
p but uh you just are given this already
complex common
p but here q is a real as i mentioned
before
if you only care about the part of p
then you can set it to be real
the blue highlight and blue part is kind
of like for experts
which really highlights the difference
from the
regular uh traffic itself um so what
it's saying
is that if q is real then the phase back
the symmetrically factor and this is
what you mentioned set
is unique and uh these conditions
uh it's a hard to memorize if this is
the first time you see it
but once you go through it the number of
times these are accurately natural
conditions
some degrees and parity and
normalization conditions
this normalization one's particularly
important in mind it's a little bit
cryptic
but just remember u is a unitary matrix
it naturally says that p squared this
part
plus one minus x squared q squared you
want so that's it
so it's a very non-trivial
constraint on this point on q
immediately the culinary corollary of
this uniqueness result
is that there's a one-to-one mapping uh
between the global minimizers so you
don't
need to worry about the face factors
anymore uh you
there's a one-to-one mapping between the
global minimizers and all the
diminishable pairs of this polynomial pq
such that the real parts of p is what
you want
so in other words um if you
what you're given is a real polynomial f
then
what you really want to do is to find
the so-called complementary
polynomials the imaginary problem p and
q
both are real so that they satisfy
all the natural conditions together with
this normal position condition
but this seems to be a quite a hopeless
problem
because just by noting this thing
on the left hand side is something you
know you can factorize it
and the right hand side doesn't even
look very much factorizable
because you have there's a p's and q's
it seems like
it's even hard to figure out
whether there are like a finite number
of local minima
or they're actually uh like an infinite
so this is really the first thing we
need to
do in order to go anywhere um it seems
like
there's infinite number of choices and
in these two papers
they did provide a concrete construction
for class assumptions but
it's not clear whether
all those solutions can be constructed
in that way
so the the first step we want to show
then
is to show that there are actually a
fine number of choices
the key here is to use a
important idea raised by the paper
and to convert this a regular polynomial
of the lower long numbers that's just a
recall very simple fact that for any x
that is one minus one to one
and i can always write x to be z plus z
inverse divided by two
where z is this space so let's leave
just uh
rotate here and this is the project the
real part
is projected to minus one and one
then you give me any real polynomial has
x i can just do this substitution
then this becomes f z plus z inverse
over two
and this becomes a long polynomial in
this uh
slightly more complicated range is the
inverse
okay so um so
this few lines requires a little bit of
population but i'm
just going to emphasize the importance
of it rather than letting you
go over the derivation the the important
thing
of this factorization which really takes
a few lines
is to say that if you look at this thing
on the right hand side it really doesn't
look factorizable
but on the right on this if you write in
terms of z and
v inverse this is factorizable
so this uh this p imaginary is exactly
what you want
this p major x but with this x to the
substitution
and q here what this means
is uh on the left hand side
if you can factorize and find all the
rules
of this function test in terms of uh
this rules for the this factor is the c
minus r
then this pins down all the roots of the
right hand side because the right hand
side is a form of this
product and if all the rules
of this laurent polynomials can be
pinned down
then what it means is all the solutions
of the global minimizers
must be just some sort of combination of
the rules from the
f and there are finite this immediately
means that
there's a finite number of global
minimizers
so the procedure is
a little bit messy therefore i'm not
showing you here
what i just want to say is that if you
follow this procedure
you can generalize the results in
the uh jslw and the
hard paper to find all the global
minimizers
with this procedure okay so
this means we have a constructive way
which however if you really want to do
this this is only a conceptual procedure
if you really want to do this you still
need to use the
variable for zero arithmetics or
essentially here we'll assume
there's a like a implement uh procedure
that is used
but nonetheless it says uh you
have a way to find all the global
minimizers of
the spacecraft but
um another reason i'm not showing all of
them is because
in practice what we found is you don't
care about
most of them you actually only care
about one of them
and this one is a very special one
this is uh you will see this a couple of
times for the rest of the talk
and which is power four zero zero zero
column
is used in the qsp pack for all the
numerical examples
it is robust so far for the examples we
have tested
this robot for virtually all real target
functions
that's it uh what this means is if you
plug in this space vector
into the curiosity representation it
tells you to represent
px equals the i times
the d folder check check and q is the
d minus one voltage chemistry second
second kind in particular this px is
purely imaginary
means that the real part is zero so this
is actually one special solution
for the very trivial case
which is f
so why this one is
particularly important is because we
found that
there are some very nice properties near
the solution
the convergence of the optimization is
actually much faster
and it has also a larger conversion
space
i'm going to show you first with some
numerical results
one thing that i want to say is that
um uh before that one thing i want to
say
is a interesting numerical observation
which is also important
that uh this f the infinite number
of f because it's encoded by unitary
it has to be bounded by one but if the
infinite norm
gets a approaches one the optimization
problem is actually very ill conditioned
it can actually be arbitrarily ill
conditioned as
this one minus eta this eta goes to zero
and this is shown in a number of cases
um
uh compounding simulation this
eigenstate filtering matrix inversion
they have this universal behavior when
the
uh integrated norm goes to one this
problem
optimization problem becomes a better
variable condition
so um for representing a real polynomial
it doesn't hurt
to just multiply by a small fact
factor in front let's say multiply f x
by c
so c is smaller than one so we always
assume
the infinite norm is a bundle away from
one let's say
it's about half or something so now
uh let's study us this
for any given function and for example
this guy
it's a random linear convolution chapter
polynomials
i just scale this function towards zero
what would happen
so we just study a few classes
depending on us this
table of infinity or this small constant
10 to the minus k converges to zero
where does it converge to
this class one converges to the
important initial guess i talked about
before
the rest of them they converge pretty
much to some other type of polynomial
one thing you've seen is that
this guy really stands out in the sense
that
when the norm of the
infinite norm of f converges to zero
it converges to the initial gas way
faster
what it means is that this particular
branch uh
which we call it a maximal solution the
reason why it is on maximally not shown
with size it's called technical reasons
but it's also this branch is generated
by a version
of this g and r method
so this max this branch of the maximal
solution
corresponds to this phi zero which sort
of has the largest convergence basin
so it is much flatter around the
solution so you start from that it's
easier to local uh the global meaning
so this is the one thing you can also
ask
uh whether this the convergence is
actually faster
this is also true because you start from
like various of this uh like initial
gases
you can all kind of convert to different
global minima
but around this phi zero
the convergence is almost always the
fastest
so uh theoretically
you can actually uh show
that uh like a why this is the case
at least there is a partial answer and
this is the following theorem
says if you uh denote this phi star
to be the maximal solution corresponding
to the phase vectors
uh so that this guy is bounded by one
stroke two
then the the two norm of the distance
between this five star
and uh this uh phi zero this pi over
four
is just a bounded by constant times the
including ones
so this is really a striking result
in the sense in particular it is
striking
because what doesn't show up uh in this
uh in this bound what doesn't show up
is the degree d so actually
you can um as this infinite norm
converges to zero
this guy converges quickly in the two
norm independently
and for nef and this is going to
uh converge at the the particular the
maximal solution bracket remember their
exponential i mean the from the correct
number of branches
but this particular branch it will
converge
to 5-0 and what this also shows
what this implies is that at least for
symmetric phase factors
the so-called capitalization technique
is unlikely to be effective
the reason is what this says is you just
add a small provision but a small
provision
leads to a small perturbation of
f who made these to a small derivation
of the phase um so while capitalization
relies on exactly the option
so you can also show that this
result i don't believe is a shark
but nonetheless it's uh i think the
first result
of this kind that if f is bounded by
one with d or d kyota which is a d over
two
then not only do you have this bound but
also you can show that the hessian of
the the
global minimum is bounded by one so
the optimization problem locally is good
and the key reason for this is that
again
at five zero you can compute the hessian
analytically
and the lambda means two and this bound
is enough to
show you that the phase factor is not
too far away
and then you only you still have this
only by one
so it shows that the hessian is positive
definite
which pretty much immediately implies
that standard optimization
algorithm would converge locally
okay so uh maybe in the
final very few minutes i'll just quickly
say something about
what this leads to which is a matrix
product state-based optimization method
uh so i mean uh again
this is uh probably not that obvious the
first time you see it but
you see it a couple of times you will
see this a qst actually
is a pretty interesting structure
because the naturally corresponds to a
matrix product state there's a bunch of
two by two matrices
and you only care about the problem and
exactly what you do
with the matrix product state with a
bound dimension too
so acute idea that we thought about is
how about just applying
this sweeping algorithms in matrix
problem state
which corresponds to some coordinate
descent method
to optimizing the phase factors just to
see how much
uh it works so i mean the the function
value
takes this thing it's a tensor format
here the left is a vector right of the
vector in the middle you have two vacuum
matrices
if you're familiar with this uh
graphical
notation uh should be pretty clear what
this is doing
uh and w in the middle of the two by two
matrix and
all this phase and x those are the
external maps
so you just do a contraction it will
allow you
to uh compute one uh uh
objective function value you could
compute the gradient pretty easily
with just uh some slight injection of
structures
of the uh for this mps structure
and then you can just uh do the sweeping
so the cost is about
d square per sweep and you can choose
various uh switching directions at the
centers and would add some loot
versions and so on and so forth so
let me report some numerical results
that um the this is for honeycombing
simulation
and the convergence is very fast so
i mean with a number of few number of
sweeps and this is 10 to minus 13
and similarly if you do it for the
for the matrix inversion problem and
pretty much six iterations here at the
machine through syrian
and this is for a couple of hundreds of
face factors that you can do
much larger um you can also prove
based on all the preparations so far uh
but uh specific to this algorithm you
can also
get some convergence which is usually
the local convergence
picks the form if your initial guess is
sufficiently close to the optimal one
then blah blah but the natural question
is i mean how do you get that initial
guess but
here because of all the results that
have been
shown in all these landscape results
what you can show is something much
stronger
what you can show is that you start from
five zero this is fixed initial gas
then there exists a constant c so that
if f
the infinite norm is bounded by this
then you just have to
just converge to the maximum solution
and that's it
and there is this exponential converter
called the linear convergence uh i
should remark that
neither this or this nor it is sharp
and one of the reasons there are various
numerical evidences showing that
this is probably not sharp and one of
them is a
number of sweeps if you look at this
thing uh
it's uh linearly depends on d but
um in practice what we observe is a
pretty much
independent v so this theorem would
predict
the cost would be dq but the numerical
calculation
shows the constant much closer to b
squared
uh okay let me just uh wrap this up with
one slide of movement question
uh so this observation was made in our
carrier paper this uh numerical
algorithmic paper uh
even with all the understandings of this
uh
landscape results this word still feels
a little bit clueless
but it was such an interesting
observation and i want to share with you
here and
see whether you have uh ideas it's just
a decade
so with the decay so recall the
connection between the smoothness
of a function and
the decay of the
fourier coefficients of the function so
this is
the the duality
between the regularity of a function and
the decay or
in the fourier domain so especially if
the function
is c infinity then in the fourier domain
the fourier coefficients really decay
super algebraic if the functions the eva
analytic
and the fourier domain should be
exponential so
the similar arguments can be carried out
for capture form coefficients as well
but what we didn't expect at all
was that uh there is a corresponding
decay behavior
for the face vectors so uh what i'm
showing here on the
y-axis is the magnitude showing for
several examples you can try
various other things the observation the
same thing
that these functions they are smooth
and the chapter of coefficients they
will
have a decay exponential decay or even
super extensive decay
but what we didn't expect at all was the
symmetric phase factor
very important the symmetric phase
factor it
very closely follows the decay of the
chapter coefficient
we were very excited last year and
thought we
would like to make a direct connection
but then later we
uh encountered this so many
global minima so many local minima i
mean this one i mean which solution
does this belong to i mean we don't even
know how to characterize
this decay at all now at least we have
the language
to talk about the problem although to to
show the decay there are
important technical roadblocks there
the land we should talk about the decay
would be the phase factor corresponding
to the maximal solution
satisfies this dependency so at least we
can write down a conjunction
but still how to do that
with no idea and if you're interested
i'll be more than that to
talk about like why technically there's
something difficult
and thank you very much
thank you thank you for the nice tall
queen
um we we still have time for a few
questions
so if anyone wants to ask something
please write in the chat or
speak up
hi folks hi and lyndon that that was a
fantastic talk and really beautiful
results
gosh you keep on coming up with these
one after another
and i'm curious on this last question
that you raised which is very
provocative
whether it might be due to a
relationship between the algebras of
polynomials and the algebras of phase
coefficients
so for example we can add two
polynomials
does that that doesn't imply the phase
coefficients add
and i'm curious if you have any
intuition
about how one might construct what those
what kind of homomorphisms you might
have there
uh so we thought about um um
using more uh like some more structural
results
to prove any of those things before we
competed
uh so at least that means i have a very
limited we have very limited
understanding of the structural of this
character i think we're really at the
even the the the the tip of the iceberg
or something there must be something
profound
there but we don't know so far in order
to prove the results we know
is pretty much based on brute force
complications that's why i'm not showing
you so it really needs to like appeal
like like onions you peel from one layer
to another
but there's a very nice introduction
that you can show that allows you to
prove certain results
but the the thing that uh
prevents us from proving such results is
because many of those things other than
that one theorem i showed before is the
independent due to
some very delicate telescoping
cancellation
uh everything depends on d which means
that if you want to talk about decay you
gotta have some way to talk about the
bottom space to talk about the
d goes to infinity but everything we
have so far
is pretty much fine id when you
transform from one one to another you
lose a square root of b
i mean to us is hopeless but uh i i
think
there must be some higher perspectives
on this because
that allows you to see the structure
more clearly that the world completely
improves
but you do have 1d independent results
this last one you showed us yeah
but yeah not enough starting point but
at this moment that's not enough force
to
show thank you
i have another question so it's very
nice
you have to describe this observation
that there is
at least one solution that you can
pinpoint this maximal solution that you
that you named is there
any chance that there is some continuous
relationship between the polynomial and
the maximum
solution or or these branches out like
if you change the polynomial then this
maximum solution
just like becomes a more maximal
solution or any
structural understanding there that i
don't know
because as i said many of these
calculations are based on pretty good
population and this uh what happens when
you
reach towards some branching at some
point it must have
that they can converse there and there
but uh
the quantitative description of those is
beyond our
treatment
yeah and also another thing observation
maybe you can show as well
which is uh you can also
show that the if you define the
phase factors to be associated with a
non-maximal solution
by the way since you're definitely
expert i can say what the maximum
solution is so basically
you selected this root of this wrong
polynomial
you select the all of them to be inside
the unit circle
follow them to the outside circle and
that corresponds to the maximum
of a certain one
[Music]
so so yeah but
you can move some of the swap
some of the rules within and uh
and out inside and outside the unit
circle you get a non-maximal solution
and you probably will also get a certain
local convergence result
and we conjecture that the rate will be
slower
we're not sure but maybe square root
all right thank you once more
for the very nice talk and uh i suggest
that if anyone has any more questions
then let's take those offline because uh
we are approaching the end of day one so
thank you once again
and and uh
i'm not sure if much you want to say
some concluding words for today or
um well just just uh very quickly
um just just some you know first uh
thanks to all the speakers for
for great talks and secondly um just an
announcement that um
now that the we just have word that the
mask mandate has been lifted
so anybody who's in person who can be in
person can
actually come to the auditorium tomorrow
and it'll be
much easier if uh to both attend and
maybe
even speak so that there's uh you know
assuming all goes well so so look
forward to seeing you tomorrow
and thanks andras for for sharing the
session